and Nexus Center crust okay you don't
have reps to wait all right picture
tummy in there you don't have your
attendant if you need intend me to you
have a mom he'll strike when they come
in range your first thing should be
native interface
if that footwork right here's the line
don't reach from right to left or left
to right
Kevin walk
you are very sleepy right now
Kimmy's 50% your training time engage
your Center and you don't have any
change
get this bike in there stop go again get
that strike in there stop forgetting it
through the line
if it get it up earlier than that don't
reach left to right get back hand on the
center line that's where your other hand
picks it up new rep cycles too slow Josh
and doing like two two one three two one
so look at we took a long time maybe
getting here where you have this kind of
mechanical manipulation of this bus so
to get his energy
that's just joint manipulation so his
energy his push is what I have to boil
around my heart not his joints his hits
this push I make him go around my yes my
waiting sink
okay so joint manipulation that's not
power the steps energy energy
you push it and it's going around
now you're going to want to do this I'm
not doing that I feed it into this
certain point I'm going around it so I
have an attendance bottle inside his
Queenie energy around my house and I
have to be soft
otherwise that would come down to him
then we will get lost so as he's
pointing around the I continually
release my tension in my waters
now martyr they push the less movement
things that bigger result
[Music]
okay strike
that's getting that just resist the
temptation to push when you've got it
okay so this this energy cannot coil
around that are you doing that are
manipulation okay you go same thing
right it's never it's it's already
possible right and you see where you
have that mechanical flawed there
because your elbows out sides are
automatic so it's different it is it is
okay so when I do the first one I never
did this you guys did that so my elbow
is inside and I'm keeping that same pop
you see and did my body like okay so
when he's pushing out of block him to go
around I wanted to go I wanted it over
he's gone
[Music]
nice to me you go you go underneath
I'm going to write this out okay
right
[Music]
Oh
I do the same thing
oh I might have to shoot my way this one
open
[Music]
Chay's hundred you just come in and push
go ahead and shop in much three more
[Music]
so get some cowboy up oh come on oh I
don't want it over overclock so we get
rid of the Oh
Philippe's okay let's go get into you
watch that complaining
[Music]
bravo Bravo Robert I'd grab his head
push the soil is too crappy for for the
energy applications so we're going to
just work on the soil
okay Hank g1 okay
[Music]
because
I want you to do I want you to do not
heart then I want this despite okay oh
you not let them live
[Music]
her energy is going around so we're
trying to take the inward spiral and
stop making it in Canada and we're
trying to make it energetic
[Applause]
reject it
now
[Music]